hello and welcome to this video playing
assassin for King assassin for King okay
he wants to assassinate me with the
London system oh my god I'm shaking in
my boots
Captain Obvious I know he five before
give me a piece
I know that the setup looks a bit odd
yeah but it's not so bad I can play g6
Bishop g7 and then II five at the end
it's kind of ok what setup is so slow
that you can do stuff like that
ok now maybe is this one I can try to
irritate him a little bit more even and
it gives me the pair of bishops that's
nice
the area so that Bishop h4f g5
you
I want some imbalance in this pollution
Shapira is a good imbalance to have
so you please
place with the Queen to eat - maybe he
wants to go a five and disposition I'm
not sure IKEA hey I still have those
useful moves like b6 and so on and maybe
I should have considered to play a six
first actually
six is not a big deal but near Bishop a
six is something that irritates me quite
a bit
yeah
okay
now d5 looks a lot like a bad French
defense let's not do that
you
let's not do that
my main idea okay now he has stopped my
main idea was to play for him um the
capture on e5 and then try to make a
five look week we just wants to trade
trade down really okay and I don't want
to trade I mean not that it would be bad
but there's no reason to trade
you
just no reason to trade I mean the word
queen does not have a fantastic squares
and sitting right in [ __ ] in dead g44
Kim okay let's go by five threatened g4
if he goes G for himself we have Knight
f6 which threatens to capture again okay
now here we look down
now about take it's a check so I can
take first and make the white king I
think I should do that
and he loses castling now um yeah I
think taking is good
really
okay
okay now let's let's test spin out I can
take the tool that would win it's
naughty for better and also just win
this right
night come on yeah keep it simple come
on and now the rook is hanging and when
yet he has to take the knight him okay
that was a bit a bit less shaky than the
game before okay so the London yeah you
can do many things d6 is kind of it's a
bit odd but it's not so bad
the basic idea is what I played in the
game play 45 and what he did is I mean
Bishop d3 is not that great you know you
should probably play as the engine
suggests was some kind of c4 like this
and then I probably switched to the
setup Bishop g7 castles 27 it's okay no
I mean this is not a big issue for white
but it irritated him aged 6 for 9 h5
it's funny they stock fish has night FD
2 as one of the moves preventing night
h5 I cared I mean he can play like this
this is there's nothing wrong about
White's position it's very solid ok and
now I don't like to be 6 with hindsight
I should probably play it differently
maybe a six first I can of course play
e5 that is what the engine gives us the
main movement this is in a way the most
conservative choice I just stopped
White's a5 and make the bishop look a
little bit sad it's so ever very
aesthetic and this is why I didn't like
it so much but it's probably what I
should do if he pushes d5 then something
like c6 makes sense yeah I have this
idea this is probably the best move just
purely just objectively speaking be 625
there should be seven push before I
think this is kind of normal
I don't like d5 yeah I can do this and
this but my bishop looks sad and this is
not clear what it's doing it's very
difficult to play f6 not with the pawns
being here and I don't see my counter
play so the CAPTCHA is certainly more
normal castled and now he took on these
six I was expecting something like this
and then I would have taken trying to
play against this pawn but it's not not
easy at all
I think I prefer white chair but I mean
the computer says it's equal but I think
I would rather be white
he took on d6 and now played this odd
Queen h4 maneuver and this is not a good
idea he just loses time and he doesn't
have really good squares to go to yeah
wherever the Queen goes h3 is one of
them problematic squares f5 and now here
he stumbled into into this trick now but
it's not easy to give him an advice I
mean where to go
yeah Queen h2 or something I've good e5
I mean this is already a strong scent
and he provoked that with all his cream
mousse I mean I got all those moves for
free and now I have just a big Center
yeah and he stumbled into the 90 of 6
idea now he should go of course Knight
age 2 and then yeah I thought he 5
probably and it's what the engine wants
to play it makes sense he's still on
this square so let's say castles I don't
know where yeah if he castles Queen side
I check on d4 so probably short and then
the engine gives f4 yeah that looks like
a good idea
he just has weird pieces there yeah
that's the thing I also check no no can
we no other all the material rook age 16
to hell but it's just a piece down okey
guys thanks for watching